[Music]
yeah
thank you day for this tremendous hor
and enjoy the Heritage [Music] Classic
how'd that one feel clouder we should
just play here for every home game the
excitement is high practice was great
great to be out there for a lot of
guys this is you know one for Twice a
Lifetime right so try to enjoy it here
go it's awesome it's like you know
brings back my memories when I was
a kid right like you know skating at
the other rings and stuff two teams
that are dying for a win and it's going
to be a bottle of Alberta tomorrow for
[Music]
sure
[Music] [Applause] [Music]
[Applause] [Music] [Applause]
ready to take the Battle of Alberta outside
the Flames of Oilers in the Tim Horton
Heritage Classic from soldout Commonwealth
Stadium all right guys let's have a good game
here moving the and an advon
are kid has the opening
goal comes up again scores
McKenzie wigger tipped in
front yeah let's go what a
pass Le come on goce go nice I
got W let's go baby as a four game windless
streak for the Oilers has ended here at commonwell
stadium